I'm joined today by David litt who is a
former speechwriter for President Barack
Obama also author of the book thanks
Obama
my hope each Ange White House years
David it's so great to talk to you I was
very interested in the book let's start
with how you ended up in this position
of being a speechwriter particularly at
such a young age for President Obama I
was one of those college kids I
graduated college in 2008 and I didn't
plan on going into politics at all I was
trying to figure out what I wanted to do
I interned for the onion the the comedy
newspaper I applied to join the CIA and
was rejected and I'm January 3rd 2008 I
was watching the free cable
on a flight that little plane TV and the
seat back in front of me and it was CNN
was on and Barack Obama was delivering
his victory speech after the Iowa
caucuses and within a few minutes of
watching that speech I was one of those
young people whose lives was just
changed forever I mean by the time that
plane landed I was like okay whatever
this guy is doing I want to be part of
that does the CIA tell you why they've
rejected you when they reject you they
did in my case they they called me up
and they said let's just get kick things
off
have you used any illegal substances in
the last year and I thought about lying
to the CIA because I thought maybe
that's the and maybe this is a test but
actually I decided you know maybe I
shouldn't risk it so I told them the
truth I had smoked pot two months
earlier as my 21st birthday and they
instantly said you know okay well that's
it interview over
you know we remember they said we like
rule breakers but in this case we we
have to say we cut off the interview
unless you've you've been clear of
illegal substances for 12 months got it
so you enter and what are sort of the
initial speech writing assignments that
you do I started off at the White House
as a speechwriter to Valerie Jarrett who
was President Obama's senior adviser and
in a lot of ways it was a really lucky
job because she knew both the president
and the first lady for decades by the
time I met her and so I got an insight
into into the president that a lot of
people maybe wouldn't have gotten a
chance to because Valerie knew him so
well and then I also wrote for other
senior staff and for a long time my
niche with presidential speech writing
was basically what no one else wants to
do so if there was a video taping that
everybody else said you know we're
already busy this week and this doesn't
seem like a lot of fun and we're hoping
someone else can do it I was that
someone else for about a year or two and
gradually picked up more and more
responsibilities as time went on so
let's start with sort of those minor
speeches how much back and forth and
revising is there even for the really
minor speeches for the really minor
stuff there was not a ton of
back-and-forth with the president so for
example we would often take a big speech
that week and condensed it into that
week's weekly address I would sometimes
do the condensing but it's not like
President Obama was meeting with us to
say well I already delivered this speech
but this short version is it good also
you know he would trust that the process
would turn out something that was good
enough for that what we would have a lot
of is back and forth with the chief
speech writer who was jon favreau in my
in the first term my first few years
there and Cody Keenan in the second term
and he both of them knew the president's
voice really well and would be
responsible for going through it and
making sure that whatever I wrote or one
of our other speech writers wrote was
something that the president wouldn't
have to edit that intensely if it was
smaller and then the other thing we did
a lot of was fact-checking so even the
smallest videos were very intensely
fact-checked I imagine that sort of a
contrast with the current administration
I I imagine so yeah now as far as
writing for the president's style what
are some of the interesting particulars
that you could share of things you sort
of picked up in terms of the tone and
style that would be written in well the
biggest thing that I noticed about
writing for President Obama and it's one
thing I share in the book is he could
read a run-on sentence in a way that
most speakers cannot I mean if you're
watching this
and we're listening to this and you're
thinking I want to be a speech writer
one piece of advice I would normally
offer is write short sentences because
most speakers can't handle long
sentences they get lost in them
President Obama was such a good orator
and had such a good sense of audience
and timing that he could punctuate a
sentence himself so he could take a
run-on sentence and break it up
naturally and build to these crescendos
and often those were the most inspiring
moments in a speech so it was actually
something I almost had to unlearn and
relearn when I started writing for him
because in the past I had been working
very hard to keep sentences very very
short and now is this chance to kind of
unwind them and let him his sort of
natural extraordinary talent shine
through what in the world that you were
in of speech writing is considered sort
of like a major accomplishment or
success and what would be sort of like a
nice oh great moment well I think
there's all sorts of different
definitions of success I mean certainly
a big speech like the State of the Union
or a important speech something after a
national tragedy and I never held the
pen on any of those those were usually
the chief speechwriter or maybe the
deputy one one sort of rung down on the
speechwriting ladder but for me it was
you know the biggest features I probably
worked on were the Correspondents Dinner
speeches the jokes and the other thing I
write about a lot in the White House is
in a way I didn't fully appreciate when
I started there what success looks like
is managing to do your job in a way that
doesn't derail what everyone else is
trying to do in a big way because little
mistakes can have these huge
consequences I mean in the book I write
about time I accidentally caused an
international incident I write about a
time when Fox News picked up on some
small thing in a speech that I did and
it should have been innocuous but it
became a story for a day and so every
moment you're trying to not necessarily
make history not necessarily swing for
the fences but even in those less
historic moments you're just trying to
get it right let's talk about the
Correspondents Dinner how did you get
pulled into that was it because of your
background with the onion that sort of
made people aware like
maybe we want to talk to David litt
about this yeah I had what in DC passes
for a comedy background so I had my
onion internship I had done improv
comedy in college I started my speech
writing life as a writer at a firm
called West Wing writers which is a
private sector firm and one of the
speech writers there Jeff Nussbaum has a
niche where he writes a lot of jokes for
public figures so I had had some
experience writing jokes for politicians
too
and when I started at the White House
the speechwriter in charge of writing
jokes was John Lovett who's now a host
of POD save America and moved to LA and
he moved to LA in November 2011 so it
was really after he left that there is
the sense of like we need someone to be
our in-house token funny person and no
one else is there who's gonna fit the
bill so by default that kind of became
me so when you're writing jokes it would
seem to me that the standard for
evaluating how it went is very different
than when you're writing a serious
speech I mean how do you pay attention
to how that speech goes over I think
there were two important things for us
so one is when you're writing comedy
even for a politician even for a
president it has to be funny we were
always trying to do stuff that was
legitimately getting a laugh out of the
audience and it was easier for us than
for many other speech writers because
President Obama has such a good sense of
timing but it still takes a lot of work
and I go into all that work in the book
the other thing that was important for
me and for the the team of people
writing jokes was that in some small way
this was worth the president's time so
there's no question that going and doing
a correspondence that it was not the
most important thing President Obama was
gonna do that month or that week or
sometimes even that day but we still
tried to think about are we expressing
our point of view or we may be telling a
little truth about Washington are we
using self-deprecating jokes to make it
clear that while President Obama takes
his responsibilities seriously he
doesn't take himself too seriously so
even the things that seem totally
innocuous you think if the president is
gonna put his own time into making this
good then we want to make sure it in
some way helps him in his broader job so
no
what the process is behind the scenes or
at least what it was with President
Obama what do you make of or what do you
think is happening behind the scenes
with the writing of the speeches given
by the current president and and I don't
know if maybe the problems come when he
goes off of the written speech and maybe
if you have any experience and sort of
managing that didn't really seem to be a
concern with President Obama but what's
your analysis of what you see coming out
in terms of presidential speeches right
now so our goal I think it's fair to say
when the speechwriting team that I was a
part of our goal was always to make
President Obama sound like himself
because with the speeches we wrote I
would I wouldn't the highest compliment
I could imagine for a speech that I
wrote is is the kind of thing President
Obama would have written himself if he
had the time and I don't know that we
ever got quite there but the closer we
got the happier we were certainly the
happier I was um I think and in the book
I say that speech writers are more
personal trainers than puppet masters
they can make you present the best
version of yourself to the world they
can't put words in your mouth and turn
me into somebody or not and I think that
is the challenge for the current crop of
speech writers in the Trump White House
because President Trump is who he is and
I think we see him when he doesn't have
a script in front of him we see a
reflection of exactly who this person is
sometimes you get the sense that the
speech writers are hoping to hide who he
is by giving him remarks that you know
quote/unquote sound presidential but
it's not it's not gonna work in the long
term and so they're trying to do
something that speech writers have never
been able to do successfully and I think
I think this group of speech writers
isn't able to do successfully which is
pretend that somebody is a different
person than the one that we see
regularly on TV the other thing that's
interesting about this group of speech
writers is I think they have more
influence over the president then
particularly Stephen Miller the chief
speechwriter then other speech writers
in the past because Donald Trump is the
kind of person who listens to the last
person who was in the room he doesn't
have a thoughtful way of making
decisions and so what happens is
if Stephen Miller the chief speechwriter
is the last guy to edit the speech to
talk to the president he can manipulate
the president into saying something that
is closer to his kind of hardline white
nationalist view of the world then maybe
some of the president's other advisers
were there situations with President
Obama where for whatever reason he would
sort of start to depart from the written
speech and and riff and if so does that
worry you that maybe he doesn't like
what's been written or is it just sort
of hey this is President Obama he has
this ability to do this we don't worry
about it in the first term I think for
the most part President Obama was fairly
what's the right word he was you placed
a lot of stock in not ad-libbing unless
he felt he absolutely had to and the
reason for that is that anything that
you say in the first term of the
presidency can be taken out of context
and put in a political ad so it's not
just a question of what you're trying to
get across but whether someone can
misinterpret that and that's hard to
judge and figure out on the fly in the
second term I do think President Obama
went off-script a little more I know
with the jokes there were one or two
times he improvised the whole run of
jokes and you to his credit would never
know just watching it which ones were
scripted and which ones weren't so to
your question honestly there weren't a
lot of times when he would go off script
and I'm worried that it meant that he
didn't like the remarks at all because
they weren't usually totally changing
everything generally speaking I was kind
of curious to see what he would say and
also aware that odds were pretty good
that that was gonna be the part of the
speech where you know everybody my
friends and family would say like that
was amazing did you write that part and
I'd say well you know I wrote the speech
like yeah try to try to dodge the
question a little bit so we were very
lucky not many speech writers get to
work for someone who when they start to
go off script you think oh this is gonna
be good
I think a lot of speech writers have the
opposite feeling yeah particularly right
now I would say we've been speaking with
David litt former speechwriter for
President Barack Obama the book which is
fascinating is thanks Obama my hope each
ange White House years David thanks so
much for talking to us and best of luck
with the book thank you so much it's
great to be here